voy a tomar la región definida más bien
la región que se encuentra entre esta
curva en amarillo una curva que está en
función de qué es
x igual al menos 1 al cuadrado y esta
recta en azul que es igual a x menos 1
voy a tomar entonces esta región que
tenemos aquí y la voy a rotar la voy a
rotar alrededor de la recta de igual a
menos 2 para obtener una figura como
ésta que parece algo así como el frente
de una turbina de avión y lo que
queremos hacer es calcular el volumen de
este sólido podríamos hacerlo con el
método que ya conocemos que es el método
de discos aquí tendríamos nuestros
discos uno de estos discos y estaríamos
integrando para x el problema que se
presenta aquí al observar la región es
que aquí tienes un límite inferior para
el disco y aquí tienes otro límite
inferior distinto por lo cual para
hacerlo por el método de discos
tendríamos que separar la región en dos
pero como no tenemos ganas de separar la
región en dos vamos a encontrar el
volumen por el método de cascarones
sobre todo porque esta curva ya está
expresada en términos de ye y para la
recta va a ser muy fácil expresar lo así
y lo que vamos a hacer de nueva cuenta
es imaginar que tenemos aquí unos
rectángulos aquí tenemos uno de esos
rectángulos cuya altura es de g y vamos
a imaginar que esos rectángulos van a
girar alrededor de la recta de igual a
menos 2 déjame dibujar por aquí estos
rectángulos que cuando giran generan un
cascarón
aquí tenemos uno de esos rectángulos y
aquí lo tenemos por abajo
y cuando esto gira aquí tenemos el
cascarón que se va formando tiene un
cierto espesor el espesor es de iu y
aquí lo tenemos aquí se puede apreciar
claramente el cascarón que genera ese
rectángulo al girar y cuyo espesor es de
y déjame darle un poco de sombra para
que tenga la perspectiva en tres
dimensiones de este cascarón y como
hemos hecho en problemas similares la
meta aquí es que encontremos el volumen
de este cascarón para una y específica y
después
integraremos sobre las 'íes' para
obtener el volumen total del sólido así
que lo que vamos a hacer ahora es como
hemos hecho en problemas anteriores
obtener cuál es el radio de este
cascarón cuál es el radio este cascarón
este que estoy poniendo en magenta y
cómo podemos ver aquí básicamente va a
ser la distancia entre igualados e
igualados y el valor específico para y
de ese cascarón esta distancia va a ser
el radio aquí la tenemos lista
2 y el valor específico para y de ese
cascarón
así que si esta distancia le llamamos
esta distancia le vamos de aquí aquí hay
2 por lo cual la distancia total sería
de más 2 otra manera de ver esto es que
la distancia total es menos -2 con lo
cual nos da yemas 2 entonces el radio
del cascarón va a ser igual a ye más 2
lo acabamos de calcular radio es igual a
más 2 y si el radio es igual a 2
entonces la circunferencia la
circunferencia de este cascarón va a ser
igual a 2 y por radio 2 por 100 más 2
ahora el área de la superficie externa
de este cascarón el área de la
superficie está en este cascarón esta
que tenemos aquí va a ser igual a la
circunferencia x
esto de acá que podríamos llamar el
ancho del cascarón por esta distancia o
equivalente mente esta distancia de aquí
que ya sabemos que es la función la
función que está en la parte superior
menos la función que está en la parte
inferior con respecto a los valores de
jeff y para identificar cuál es la
función en la parte superior con
respecto a y hay que identificar la
función que da los mayores valores de x
esta función la recta que tenemos aquí
en azul es la función que está en la
parte superior necesitamos expresar esta
función en términos de y para eso sumó 1
ambos lados y obtengo que x es igual a
más 1 aquí tenemos la función superior y
esta de aquí es la función en la parte
inferior puedes inclinar tu cabeza hacia
la derecha y ver que efectivamente esta
es la función superior mientras esta de
aquí la función inferior para un valor
fijo de y esta función de aquí te da un
mayor valor de x de lo que lo hace esta
esta función de aquí fija el límite
superior de los cascarones entonces el
área va a ser igual a la circunferencia
x
esta distancia por esta dimensión vamos
a escribir esto el área de cada cascarón
va a ser igual a la circunferencia que
es 2 pi porque más 2 por esta distancia
que tenemos aquí deja de ponerlo con
otro color
por qué uno sí y más uno que es el
límite superior menos el límite inferior
que sería de menos 1 al cuadrado
menos 1 al cuadrado déjame cerrar el
paréntesis en el mismo color muy bien y
entonces el volumen el volumen de este
cascarón va a ser el área superficial
externa de este cascarón por el espesor
por el espesor que es de ella y eso es
lo que va a establecer nuestra integral
luego hacer por acá lo hacen un color
neutral va a ser 2 x 2
si uno menos diez menos uno al cuadrado
y eso multiplicado por el espesor del
cascarón del integrando esto sobre el
intervalo vamos a obtener el volumen
pero cuál es ese intervalo
podrías estimarlo a ojo pero es mejor
calcularlo cuando son estas dos
funciones iguales
necesitamos saber cuándo ye más uno es
igual a menos uno al cuadrado hagámoslo
por acá tenemos entonces que ye más uno
es esto de aquí cuando es igual a esto
de acá va a ser igual voy a desarrollar
este binomio esto va a ser igual a pie
cuadrada menos dos más uno y ahora voy a
restar
y uno ambos lados menos y menos uno del
lado izquierdo y menos y menos uno del
lado derecho del lado izquierdo
me da 0 y del lado derecho me da y
cuadrada menos 2 yemen que es igual a
menos 3 y encuadrada menos 3 y más pero
aquí se cancelan estos términos esto me
da 0 y que tenemos entonces tenemos que
0 es igual al que multiplica al menos 3
nos da las coordenadas en vez de los
puntos de intersección 1 ocurre cuando
es igual a 0 y el otro cuando es igual a
3 y lo podemos ver aquí cuando es igual
a 0 tenemos este punto de intersección y
cuando llegue es igual a 3 obtenemos
este otro punto de intersección por lo
que el intervalo integración es de 0 a 3
y ya lo tenemos ya tenemos un integral
para obtener el volumen de este sólido a
través de cascarones lo que hay que
pensar ahora es cómo resolver esta
integral